Ich muss mal gucken, nicht dass es jetzt abkackt, weil ich die Unity-Media-Leitung noch ausgewählt hab.
Äh, nee, müsste gehen. Wunderbar. Nee, ich hab gestern umgestellt.
Ich hatte auch Probleme mit Telekom. Wir haben gestern auch was aufgenommen.
Also ich hab gestern auch mit jemandem was aufgenommen im Discord.
Und da hab ich zwischendrin übelst rumgeleckt. Über Telekom-Leitung hab ich umgestellt, auf Unity-Media ging.
Na ja, ist super. Ich weiß auch nicht was die Telekom da macht.
Ja, das ist immer die Frage, ne?
Mal gucken ob es heute wieder den Disconnect Sponsor bei Tealull3D gibt.
So, Stream läuft.
Ich glaub wenn du jetzt noch mal einen DCs oder so, dann können wir den nächsten nicht mehr zusammen spielen, ne?
Oh, das ist so schlimm.
Da merkste mal was das für ein System ist.
Ja, man muss da, es ist insofern, es ist ja okay. Ich mein du spielst die Carry-Klasse letztendlich und du bist nicht umsonst an die Top 500.
Das ist schon in Ordnung, aber es ist trotzdem, in vielen Bereichen sieht man einfach, es funktioniert nicht.
Diese Delusio Speedboost Runde, das war letztendlich, du hast die gekillt, aber das hätte halt sonst nicht funktioniert.
Daran siehst du das halt einfach Performance Base, das geht nicht in dem Game, das klappt nicht.
Das sind halt so Sachen wo ich mir denke, ne, so kann das ja nicht laufen.
Im Prinzip hätte ich so viele Runden auch gar nicht carryn können, wenn du nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie auf Mercy oder Reinhard da gewesen wärst.
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran, das wird halt wieder schon oft genug der Fall sein.
Wir machen jetzt, ich mach den Titel jetzt mal anders.
Wir machen jetzt nicht Master plus, sondern wir schreiben jetzt 3600 plus SR.
Ne, das schreiben wir nicht, wir schreiben Master plus, weil 3600 SR klingt viel zu low.
SR schreib ich erst ab 4000.
Das machen wir im nächsten Stream, wenn wir heute mehr gewinnen als verlieren, machen wir im nächsten Stream, Road to Grandmaster schreiben wir den Titel.
Da bin ich halt schon längst drinne.
Ja, der ist gut.
Solange wir noch in den 250er Range sind, ist alles gut.
Ist mein Chat kaputt oder ist noch keiner da?
Leute, ist jemand da?
Ich gucke jetzt mal in meinem OBS Chat, ob ich da was sehe, weil in meinem Browser sehe ich nichts.
Ah doch, das Kippenkino ist da, wohin?
Dann posten wir das jetzt mal auf.
Ich soll es dir machen, du müsstest mal alle Games zusammentragen.
So eine richtig fette Win-Loss-Ratio.
Dass man mal gucken könnte.
Ja gut, das sieht man auf dem neuen Account ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, ich habe ja nichts gemacht.
Außer, ne, ich habe den Account gemacht, Quickplay gespielt und dann direkt rankt, sonst nichts.
Also das müsste man eigentlich auf dem Account ganz gut erkennen.
Der Salatfresser ist auch am Start, moin.
Ich glaube irgendwie, das ist noch nicht richtig angelaufen, das Stream.
Twitch zeigt mir vier Zuschauer an, was definitiv ziemlich wenig ist.
Normalerweise sind es nach so ein paar Minuten immer 30, 40 und geht dann hoch bis an die 100, aber jetzt sind es 8.
Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht so richtig, jetzt sind es wieder 6.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Anzeige verpackt ist, keine Ahnung.
Hast du deinen Shoutout rausgehauen?
Ne, noch nicht, aber normalerweise warte ich immer.
Ich warte immer, bis das Stream läuft und bis das alles funktioniert und gut ist und läuft und tut und chat ein bisschen was los
und dann haue ich die Ankündigung noch raus.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal kurz warten.
Da scheint irgendwas nicht zu stimmen.
Vielleicht ist auch einfach der...
Es ist halt Freitag, oder?
Ja, aber das habe ich ja teilweise unter der Woche um 12 oder so.
Es gibt immer Leute.
Vielleicht ist der Titel auch einfach doof.
Ja, sogar mit Schreibfehler.
Habe ich?
Ja.
Wo habe ich mich verschrieben?
Kräftig.
Kräftig, ja, ich habe mich verschrieben hier.
Moment.
Kräftig, ja.
Die Rügenwalder Mühle.
Das schwankt zwischen jetzt und 6, dann war es 13, das ist irgendwie kaputt.
Ich würde sagen, wir spielen uns jetzt einfach mal warm und dann gucken wir mal.
Ich poste das jetzt noch mal auf...
auf Twitter.
Stream.
Stream ist live.
Posten wir das Ganze auch gleich noch auf YouTube, volle Ladung jetzt.
Gibt es nichts.
No face.
Oder aber, es sind gerade so viele Leute in der Overwatch-Kategorie on, muss ich mal gucken.
Nee, Deutsch ist quasi gar keiner wirklich on.
Der kam hier nicht, der Syrus nicht, eigentlich gar keiner.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht ist aber einfach nur die Benachrichtigungs-Sachen auf Twitch kaputt.
So, ich poste das noch mal kurz auf YouTube.
Ja Leute, heute geht es weiter.
Overwatch-Ranked Road to Grandmaster.
Vielleicht, mal gucken.
Gestern hatten wir Flawless Tag 8 zu 0, ging richtig ab.
Ich glaube, das hatte ich noch nie, 8 zu 0.
Also generell ein Tag, wo man nichts verloren hat.
Das kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, dass ich das irgendwann schon mal hatte.
Du hast was vergessen.
Was denn?
Du musst doch reinschreiben, der Winning-Stream.
Ah, stimmt.
Stimmt.
Okay.
Moin Patrick.
Was ist los?
Was stimmt nicht?
Ah.
Ja Patrick, ich habe den Eindruck, Twitch hat keine Ankündigungen verschickt, als ich live gegangen bin.
Weil das Stream pendelt gerade bei 8 Zuschauern rum, obwohl es normalerweise immer 40, 50 sind nach ein paar Minuten.
Ich weiß nicht, was da ist.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, stimmt.
Auch Winning-Stream muss den Titel lassen, hast du recht.
Das wird aber viel zu lang.
Wir machen wieder.
Komm, wir machen, wir machen das weg.
Wir machen wieder Winning-Stream.
Hallo Justsonics.
Heute war Flawless-Winning-Stream.
Übertreiben Sie heute mal richtig.
Ist heute die Star Wars-Primiere?
Ja, ich glaube, war das schon?
Nee, das läuft mittlerweile auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht sind die alle Kino-Gucken, das könnte echt sein.
Da muss ich auch noch hin.
Heute?
Oder die nächsten Tage?
Ich glaube eher unter der Woche.
Ja, jetzt heute ist es wahrscheinlich knackervoll.
Jetzt wahrscheinlich übertrieben voll.
Jetzt sind es 9 Zuschauer.
Sind die alles Star Wars-Gucken oder was?
Ich poste das mal auf YouTube.
Ach komm, wir spielen uns erstmal ein und danach poste ich auf YouTube, dass die Leute auch was ordentliches sehen.
Ich entweite dich mal.
Star Wars läuft seit gestern, schreibt einer gerade.
Kommst du an?
Ja.
Passt Lautstärke so von allem an die 11 Leute, die gerade da sind?
Das ist verbuggt.
Eben waren es 30, dann waren es 11, jetzt sind es wieder 19.
Das ist einfach verbuggt, die Anzeige gerade.
Auf geht's.
Ich wollte den Titel ja noch ändern in Flawless Winning Stream.
Weißt du, wer jetzt du schreibst rein Flawless und dann das erste Game.
Kann schon sein.
Jetzt fliegst du raus, aber wie?
Max Streamer in 1080p, das gibt die Bandbreite leider auf Twitch nicht her.
Also nicht meine Bandbreite, sondern die Bandbreite auf Twitch.
Du kannst nur maximal 6 bis, also ich müsste mal ausprobieren, ob es wirklich, ich habe
Gerüchte gehört, dass es jetzt bis 6,5 geht.
Allerdings, Twitch sagt 6 MBit Rate ist Schluss und 6 MBit reichen nicht für ein schnelles
Game und vor allem auch ein recht kontrastreiches Game, so wie Overwatch.
1080p 60 FPS mit 6 MBit, das sieht einfach kürze aus.
Wie hoch bist du mit SR?
Nachdem wir gestern so reingehauen haben, bin ich jetzt 3662.
So, ich cue, ok?
Oh, erst mal einspielen.
Baschen, alter Baschen.
Aber Marzo, das ist ein neuer Account.
Das sieht man ja auch hier am Level.
Die anderen beiden Accounts, die ich habe, habe ich seit diesen drei nicht mehr gespielt,
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, komm, scheiß drauf, machst du einen neuen, lernst du das
Game wieder ein bisschen und mittlerweile klappt es eigentlich wieder ganz gut.
Auch wenn ich teilweise noch sehr, sehr fragwürdige Plays mache.
Übrigens, ich bin in irgendeiner Overwatch Win-and-Fail-Kompilation gelandet mit einem Clip.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, aber nicht mit dem Shatter, sondern auf Numbani, wo wir attackt haben, wo ich 5 Leute
weggehämmert habe und danach das Game gequittet wurde.
Kannst du dich daran erinnern, wo wir den ersten Punkt übelst schnell eingenommen haben
vor ein paar Tagen und danach einer raus ist und das Game abgebrochen wurde?
Was stimmt denn da?
So, was haben wir denn hier für Leute am Start?
Zeig mal her.
Mercy Main?
46 Stunden!
Außer Mercy, sonst nix im Endeffekt hat er.
Skillei.
Cool Guy ist Lucio Main und Malkorn ist Hanzo-Shimada Main ist er.
Ok, da ist kein Tank dabei, ich muss mal wieder.
Was will er?
Was haben sie im Chat schon wieder für Probleme?
Keine Ahnung, was da los ist.
Hallo Sargent Tuckz und Muri1904.
Nachdem wir uns warmgespielt haben, poste ich dann auf YouTube die Ankündigung, da wird's
wieder voll oder voller.
Und Ende sind übelst kalt.
Ich bräuchte so auch diese Wärmepads, die die Pros immer haben.
Weißt du welches dieser Netzwerksymbole links jetzt welche Symbole was bedeutet?
Es gibt ja diesen Kreis mit dem Blitz und dann gibt es diese drei Dinge hintereinander
bei den Symbolen.
Die drei Karten sind uns Paketverlust.
Ok, ich hab meistens den Kreis mit dem Blitz, was auch immer der genau heißt.
Wow, ich wollte gerade Steuerung N machen, das ist vielleicht auf dem Reinhardt nicht
so gut.
Bäm.
Zehn Prozent klein.
Hook mich, hook mich.
Gehen wir mal langsam zurück.
Die pushen übelst rein.
Hammern, hammern.
Bricht, bricht.
Ey Leute, könnt ihr mal ran?
Fuck.
Mein Schild ist halt übelst kaputt.
Wir haben gar nichts im Highground zu contesten.
Die Mercy hat schon Ulti.
Kriegt man nicht, ne?
Wie hat das gelaufen?
Ich kann doch ein bisschen Ult-Charge generieren.
Moin Twitch-Mason.
Hallo Kx20 und eine Taube ist auch am Start.
Wer ist seine Arme?
Ich hab gleich Ulti, das war noch ganz gut.
Schön noch mal ein bisschen Damage gemacht.
90 Prozent Shatter.
Also wenn ich einen Fire Strike treffe, hab ich Ult.
Huge Ult kommt jetzt gleich.
Oh nee, folgen die Zarya rein.
Nein, Zarya.
What the fuck.
Schön geblockt.
Ich hab noch keinen Shatter, ein Prozent.
Eisch.
Das ist mega unkoordiniert gerade.
Das Börsen Lusche da rechts auf der Seite,
wir pushen da alle rüber und verlassen den Spot.
Huge Ulti.
Ich treff nichts.
Ja, ich bin auch noch richtig aufgewärmt.
Jetzt haben wir 40.
Jetzt haben wir 40 Zuschauer.
Jetzt ist anscheinend das Twitch Anzeige einfach kaputt.
Die kann Top, das heißt nicht Gören und so was,
und Babes und Chicks, das sagt man nicht.
Auf Twitch sagt man Grills.
Das musst du dir merken.
Wenn du öfters auf Twitch spielst
und willst dich negativ auffallen.
Fuck.
Ich bin auch noch drinnen.
Die Zarya ist fast tot.
Das war ein bisschen sehr overextended von mir.
Wir haben uns gereckt.
Scheiße, Graf.
Fuck.
Ich kriege auch nichts da.
Das ist viel zu viel Heilung.
Nice, nice, nice.
Huge, huge.
Die Tracer ist 100% smart.
Die geht übelst ab.
Das machen sie normalerweise auf dem Rank nicht.
Du musst dich rausfokussieren, wenn du Mack rufst
beziehungsweise das Auto callst.
Ist alles tot?
Nee, es ist hinten noch.
Okay, ich komme noch mal mit der D.Va ran.
Die killt jetzt halt alles noch, oder was?
Wo ist sie denn?
Ist sie tot?
Sind die wieder da?
Ich bleibe mal kurz.
Der Roadhog ist ziemlich low.
Ja, das wäre ein nice.
Die Defense Matrix ist weg.
Nein.
Ich habe es nochmal gematrixed.
Wir haben den Roadhog gleich.
Gleich Ulti, 50%.
Können wir den jetzt pushen?
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Ich drücke ihn zurück.
Schon wieder 2 CP, ja Leute.
Wir suchen halt immer die besten Spielmodi für euch raus,
dass hier auch ein bisschen Content geboten wird auf dem Stream.
Was ist da rechts los?
Nix.
Die Mercy hat geultet, warum auch immer.
Rechts, rechts Roadhog.
Was habe ich denn hier gebashed?
Roadhog fast tot.
Ich habe wieder Ulti.
Nein, nicht Ulti, Schwachsinn vergessen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann hier ein bisschen nichts fassen, oder?
Nein, anscheinend nicht.
Ich hätte fast wieder Auto am Start gehabt.
Ich glaube, ich muss nächste Runde Huge Mercy Plays rausholen.
Mercerettes gab es wenig.
Wir fühlen auch keine Ulti, aber alles gewinnt.
Es wird erst mal richtig hart durchgepusht hier.
1 an 50, das geht ja alles noch.
Das geht, das geht.
Das ist hellste Grenzen.
Max, ich finde es nice, wie aktiv du im Moment auf YouTube und Twitch bist.
Livestream macht doch übelst Bock.
Max, wie alt bist du? Ich bin 33.
Ich warte mal, was die alle so picken.
Gucken wir mal, was dieser Unic normaler mal spielt, der ist echt nicht übel.
Genji Tracer Main.
Er ist immer so in dem Dreh hier.
Ich probiere mal, was zu hocken.
Ich muss sagen, das Geile ist, wenn du auf dem Tank bist, dann ist wenigstens der Spielfluss da.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Nicht so genau.
Du meinst, dass du vorgeben kannst, wo es hingeht, oder?
Genau.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt, du hast ja recht.
Das ist ja auch wichtig.
Das ist ja auch echt wichtig.
Eines der geilsten Runden in den letzten Streams war, wo wir beide Tank gespielt haben.
Was haben wir? Winston D.Va, Combi? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Einmal Winston D.Va und einmal Reinhard. Reinhard D.Va war es, glaube ich.
Wo wir einfach die ganze Zeit durchgehämmert sind.
Moin xBuffel.
Im Team-Titel fehlt ja nur noch Link zum neuesten Video. Warum?
Junkrat.
Wo ist die Trat?
Ich sehe sie nicht. Ich glaube, die ist schon kaputt.
Falls es die überhaupt gab.
Ich glaube, du bist gar nicht rüber gedreht, oder?
Nee, ich habe sie nicht abgekriegt.
Jujuk! Jujuk! Bashen!
Direkt, direkt. Nein, nein! Lass doch nicht die Mercy retten.
Um die 10 Kilometer.
Mal gleich nochmal Blatt machen.
Bashen, Alter!
Ich habe Symmetra.
Die Mercy ist rechts außen.
Junkrat, komm her! Bam! Bashen.
Alles musst du selbst machen, ey.
Ich glaube, wir haben zu zweit gerade das komplette Team gekillt.
So ungefähr.
Also ich gehe mal links hoch auf Nileground.
Ja, ich capture mal weiter.
Du musst halt fett rein tanken.
Fett bin ich. Das passt.
Rotor kann Bauch.
Gleich Ulti am Start, 3%.
Wieso kommt der Lusche mit mir mit?
Der soll euch reinbringen. Was macht der denn?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oh, die Zamsen. Reinhardt schön am Start.
Kannst du? Oh man, das ist schon voll verkackt.
Ich push jetzt.
Wenigstens Schrank da.
So, jetzt abmarsch.
Oh oh, Achtung.
Fuck bei dir.
Nice.
Fick dich, Scheiße.
Geflasht, aber nicht gestorben.
Nein!
Oh man.
2 CP, LUL!
Huge Leute, huge.
Die Attack war wirklich extrem clean.
Richtig gut gemacht.
Aber das war der Winston, der hat verkackt.
Der hat eine Bubble gegen den Solo Tracer geschmissen.
Dann hat man keinen mehr.
Ich mach auch ein bisschen Schild kaputt.
Ich fahr wieder rein.
Der versucht mich halt reinzuhocken.
Das ist sackt ein bisschen.
Wenn der mich da reinhockt, bin ich im Arsch.
Ah, gebated.
Der hat gleich wieder Shatter, so wie ich den.
Ja, ich bin drin.
Nein!
Fuck, links.
Es kommt keiner so richtig rein.
Der Hawk ist links.
Der Reinhardt hat bestimmt gleich Shatter.
Huge, old.
2 CP, Alter, 2 CP.
Ah, ohne Witz.
Jetzt fang ich sie schon gleich an.
Report ist geil, Report ist geil.
Immer der gleiche Scheiß.
Schändiere auch zu Hawk hier.
Das hat echt gut geklappt gegen die.
Also wenn wir dann einen Tank haben.
Ich geh nicht von aus.
Nimm mal Hawk und dann guckst du mal.
Ich guck mal, genau, ich guck mal ob einer nimmt.
Nee, das ist doof.
Wir brauchen irgendwas, was die aufhalten kann, gescheit.
Wobei, komm, wir probieren das mal.
Weil Reinhardt hatte ich das Gefühl, ich hatte nicht den nötigen Support-Gefühl das letzte Mal.
Ja, das Problem war der Highground war halt weg und wir hatten niemanden, der hoch konnte.
Die Gegner haben jetzt gerade ne Widow.
Also das ist dann...
Wenn du jetzt wischen willst, dann mach schnell.
Nee, nee, ich bleib jetzt.
Die werden jetzt alle gehuckt einfach.
Mit sagenhaft 38%, easy.
Ja, Evoli, das ist auch das, was mir bei 2CP auf den Sack geht.
Um den Punkt einzunehmen, muss man gefühlt jeden viermal töten.
Das nervt mich.
Deswegen versteh ich's nicht, dass manche Pros sagen, es ist der beste Spielmodus.
Aber ich mein, ich denk mir immer, die wissen's ja besser als ich.
Oh, Mercy.
Eigentlich ist der erste Fight schon fast verloren jetzt.
Ich bin links auf dem Highground.
Kann hier.
Das ist gelaufen.
Die Mercy, ey.
Och Gott, ey.
Ey, der Aussie ist wieder da.
Huge.
Ist wieder tot.
Ja, doch stand die Mercy-RFK in der Gegend rum.
Ja, gefühlt.
Ich mein, vom Spawn von der Pharah-Rakete tohitten lassen.
Ach so, komm.
Jetzt gibt's Sachen, die müssen doch nicht sein.
Fuck, Hook raus, Hook ist rechts.
Ich geh mal nach dem Cooken.
Verrecke.
Danke, Mercy.
Wieder mal AFK gewesen.
Gibt's nicht.
Fuck.
Konnt ich nix, nix machen, das ist halt gerade.
Ich switch, ich komm mit D.Va drauf.
McCree ist rechts Richtung unseren Spawn.
Nice Bubble, das war gut.
Sag mal, man muss echt alles selbst machen, oder?
Komplett.
Ja, die Chance zu gewinnen haben wir.
Ja.
Jetzt soll man den ersten Spazier wegballen und so.
Casino, Kapitalist, ja, Ult-Charges, weißt du.
Das ist, wenn du gestunnt wirst, während der Ult ist jetzt neu, sind ein paar Patches.
Ich hab auch nicht aktiv gespielt, als der Patch kam, ich glaub, es ist auch schon bitter
und bemerkenswert, manchmal Ult gezündet zu haben mittlerweile.
Ja.
Es ist jetzt so.
Hallo, Käsebrot35, ist auch ein geiler Name.
Lass mich raten, den hast du bestimmt früher in irgendeinem MMO dir ausgedacht, oder?
Das finde ich, das liest sich wie so ein typischer MMO-Name, wenn man damals quasi
trollen wollte, so.
Wie nenne ich jetzt meinen MMO-Charakter?
Käsebrot35.
Damals in MMOs haben die Leute ja noch versucht, so Roleplay-Namen zu nehmen.
Richtig sentimentale Musik im Background.
Das ist eigentlich ein Chillstep-Relaxing-Stream.
Das hört sich eher so nach Bible-Thumb-Stream-Kranern.
Pass auf, die werden jetzt runtergeworfen auf der linken Seite von irgendwas.
Ich bin doch nicht vorne.
Ich hab zu lange rumgebatet im Spawn.
Oh, knapp.
Watt, meine Flashpring ist einfach verschwunden.
Können wir reinpushen, irgendwie?
Alter, ich treff dich hier rechts, der Hawk.
Und ein Turret.
Also, Schild hat er nicht viel.
Oh, er hat mich rechtsklickt.
Weiß nicht, du könntest mich jetzt übrigens retzen.
Nee, nee, da pushen wir jetzt nicht rein.
Ich bin halt schon drin.
Wir brauchen Push-Power, sonst geht's dann nicht vorwärts.
Was brauchen wir?
Push-Power.
Jemand, der reingeht und YOLO macht.
Wir verlieren das Game sonst.
Das Poken bringt halt nichts, ist halt nur Ultimate-Fade.
Bist du wieder da?
Ja.
Der Münzen, okay, der Münzen ist drin.
Super.
Oh, Mann.
Gibt's nicht.
Wo sind denn alle hin?
Okay, ich switch mal auf Reinhardt.
Der hat schon wieder Ulti, ich fass das nicht.
Ist der behindert dann immer, Seres?
Stehst du da, kannst du ihn nicht moveen, aber McCree kann mit Ulti dich anscharchen.
Sehr geil.
Wir haben beide auf den gleichen McCree geschossen, es war ein bisschen unlucky, dass er nicht rechtzeitig down gegangen ist.
Aber es sind ein paar verreckte, also werden wir uns jetzt beeilen.
Schon wieder fahren die einmal.
Doch, Ulti.
Was?
Mach den weg.
Der Roadhog muss weg.
Der geht hoch, rechte Seite hoch.
Ja, ich bin auch oben.
Ich bin raus.
Ich brauch hier unten Hilfe gegen den Reinhardt.
Nein, fuck.
Weggecharged.
Noch einen.
Nice.
Ich bin gerätzt, jetzt geht's los.
Noch einen.
Danke.
Haben die TP?
Ja, die haben TP.
Komm doch, vielleicht kriegen wir das schnell.
Also Earthshatter ist raus.
Okay, nice.
Ich geh jetzt auf den Highground, du gehst wieder durch.
Earthshatter 20%, Gegner hat keinen mehr.
Du musst rein, push, push, push.
Easy, die sind nicht auf den Punkt gegangen.
Die haben alle im Punkt da drüber rum gestanden und jebaited.
Die haben nichts gemacht.
Ja, pass auf, gleich rekt er mich beim in Mac einsteigen.
Ach nee, ich bin doch nicht deeper.
Easy.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir noch mehr DPS-Leute hatten oder so, ne?
Jetzt nicht.
Too easy, nee, nicht too easy.
Das war gar nicht so einfach.
Wir können mal Punkte angucken, was das gibt.
Ja.
Danach warten wir mal kurz 2-3 Minuten.
Max, wieso lässt du deine FPS zweimal anzeigen?
Gute Frage.
23, nee.
Ich hab nicht geguckt, wie viel es gab.
Leute, habt ihr es gesehen?
Ich kann im Stream gucken, ich stream-snipe mich selbst.
Fuck, zu spät, war es schon.
Ich glaube 20 Punkte oder so, 22 Leute.
Leute, habt ihr es gesehen, wie viel hat es gegeben?
Bis gleich.
Ja, warum lasse ich meine FPS zweimal anzeigen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, ich lasse es einmal in-game anzeigen und jetzt einmal von Shadowplay,
wobei ich das Shadowplay ausschalten könnte.
Soll ich das ausschalten?
Ja, komm, ich schalte das aus.
Ich schalte die zweiten FPS mal aus.
Geht das überhaupt mittlerweile?
FPS-Counter off.
Ist es jetzt weg?
Jetzt ist es weg.
24 Punkte gab es.
Dankeschön.
Es war ein recht solides Roadhog-Play, fand ich jetzt.
Die Hooks haben ein bisschen schlecht gesessen, vor allem auf die kleinen Targets.
Und manchmal hab ich auch ein bisschen bescheuert gestanden.
Und mit Reinhardt muss ich auf jeden Fall noch gucken,
ich muss mehr den Charge einbauen.
Also das, wann Ult-Charge gesammelt wird mit Hammons und so,
das finde ich, das klappt mittlerweile ganz gut.
Schild baiten, Hooks baiten, Shatterbaiten, geht auch halbwegs.
Was ich nicht richtig das richtige Gefühl bei Reinhardt für habe
und das richtige Timing bei Reinhardt für habe, ist der Charge.
Vor allem werde ich viel zu oft gebaitet von gegnerischen Reinhards,
die mich wegchargen.
Das darf eigentlich nicht sein.
Normalerweise Counter-Charges du dann, wenn du so quasi,
wenn du gegenüberstehst Reinhardt und beide Reinhards denken,
jetzt wird's gecharged, oder du hast noch ein bisschen Zeit
und siehst den Gegner Reinhardt Chargen, dann Charges du auch.
Dann sind beide Reinhards kurz gestunt.
Kommst du da? Ja, das kommt morgen.
Ich poste jetzt mal auf YouTube, dass ich am Start bin.
Aber muss sagen, bis jetzt ist Flawless Winning Stream vollkommen richtig.
Weil wir haben schon Win-Loss, immerhin 1 zu 0.
Und um nicht zu vergessen, 2 CP 0.
So, was poste ich denn jetzt mal auf YouTube?
Bin Twitch Stream Live.
Road, ich übertreibe es jetzt mal auf YouTube in der Ankündigung.
Overwatch Road to Grandmaster.
Ich schreibe jetzt mal.
Road to Grandmaster.
So, solange der EX weg ist, ich gucke jetzt nochmal in den Chat durch,
ob ich irgendwas überlesen habe.
Max, warum spielst du alle deine Spiele auf Englisch?
Ich habe mehrere Gründe.
Erstens ist die Sprachaufgabe meistens besser.
Bei Overwatch finde ich es schade, dass man es nicht auf Heldenbasis machen kann.
Zum Beispiel hätte ich gerne die deutsche Mercy in der englischen Spielversion.
Weil ich es einfach geil finde, dass die deutsche Mercy Schweizerdeutsch spricht.
Die Sprecherin in der englischen Version, das ist ja auch eine deutsche, glaube ich, Lucy irgendwas.
Ich habe vergessen, wie sie heißt.
Die macht das auch gut, aber ich finde die deutsche Mercy Sprecherin ist irgendwie nice.
Das ist besser mit Schweizerdeutsch.
Und ansonsten spiele ich die Spiele auf Englisch einfach, weil es viel einfacher ist,
im Internet Sachen zu dem Game zu finden, wenn man die englischen Begriffe kennt.
Ich meine, such mal nach Earth Shatter.
Overwatch Earth Shatter, da findest du sofort was.
Such mal nach Overwatch, wie auch immer das Ding in der deutschen Version heißt.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht so gute Sachen finden.
Und man kann sich viel besser austauschen mit Leuten,
da wenn man ranked spielt, die Kommunikation ja auch auf Englisch stattfindet.
Was übrigens eine der Sachen ist, wo Korea als auch NA Leather schon, finde ich,
einen ziemlichen Vorteil hat, was Kommunikation angeht.
Wenn man das so beobachtet, ist mein Eindruck,
die EU Leather ist das Unkommunikativste im ranked, was es gibt.
Aber ich meine, man muss sich auch nicht wundern.
Ich meine, hier spielen Leute mit acht bis zehn verschiedenen Sprachen von Russisch bis Italienisch,
Spanisch, Französisch, Deutsch, Englisch, Polnisch, ist alles dabei in der EU Leather.
Und dementsprechend haben die Leute ein bisschen Probleme dabei.
In NA ist es nicht so das Ding, die meisten reden Englisch.
Bis auf ein paar Kanadier, die Französisch reden. Franzosen halt.
Und die Koreaner haben es auch recht einfach, die reden halt Koreanisch. Easy.
Bloß wir in der EU haben halt das Problem.
Und wir können ja auch wohl schlechte eigene Leather für jedes Land machen.
Dazu haben wir einfach zu viele Länder, die zu klein sind.
Wenn die ganze Bevölkerung von Deutschland Overwatch spielen würde,
dann könnten wir eine Deutschland Leather machen.
So, wieder da. Kannst Q.
Ich muss jetzt gleich, muss man die Highlights gucken.
Wo stehen die Dinge überhaupt noch mal?
Okay, ich Q. Highlights. Wo gibt es denn die Dinge überhaupt?
Ich gucke mir das normalerweise nie an. Hier.
Highlights Roadhog Volskaya.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal, was da, was da für geile Highlights gibt.
Die meisten sind die Highlights, die das Game sich erdenkt,
was die Highlights sind. Gar nicht die wirklichen Highlights aus dem Game.
Okay, man sieht, wie ich Rechtsklicks vorbeihaue.
Und man sieht, wie ich in Reinhardt bashe.
Schön über euch drüberblase und Ulti gedrückt habe.
Na ja, gut.
Lohnt sich Overwatch noch, also bei noch zu sprechen von Overwatch
ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Overwatch ist jetzt noch eigentlich allzu lange draußen, so eineinhalb Jahre oder so, oder?
Was meinst du? Hast du es im Kopf ungefähr, Eax?
Dann kam das raus, März letztes Jahr.
Jetzt ist es aber so ungefähr eineinhalb Jahre.
Ein bisschen mehr.
Also Overwatch ist noch relativ neu. Overwatch hat sich auch verdammt oft verkauft.
Und es spielen auch auf jeden Fall noch genug Leute auf unserem Rank.
Du hast auch nicht jedes Match die gleichen Leute und sowas.
Selbst wenn du ungefähr gleich Qs.
Aber mich würden mal die echten Spielzahlen interessieren.
Weil ich meine verkaufte Einheiten und Leute, die ranked spielen, ist ja schon was anderes.
Also im Quickplay, als ich hier meinen neuen Account hochgelevelt habe,
hat ich echt das Gefühl, dass das gesamte Quickplay mittlerweile aus Smurfs besteht.
Alle unter Level 25.
Und spielen viel besser, als ein Rang Fünfer oder so spielen würde.
Joshi fragt, Max, was hältst du von Fortnite?
Ich habe es nie probiert.
Von allen Battle Royale Spielen gefällt mir das noch rein vom Sehen am besten.
PUBG habe ich gespielt. Ich fand es jetzt nicht wirklich schlecht oder so.
Es hat sich halt einfach nur unfertig angefühlt.
Vielleicht ist es besser geworden mit dem Wüstenmap jetzt.
Hast du die mal gespielt?
Das Thema hatten wir vor kurzem schon.
Echt?
Siehst du mal.
Ja gut, ich bin mittlerweile alt.
Was haben wir da gesagt?
Taugt die?
Wie gesagt, 10 Minuten habe ich gespielt.
Es hat so schlimm geleckt, dass es reinstalliert.
Okay, also die Performance von PUBG ist anscheinend immer noch absolut Weltklasse.
So wie man das nicht anders erwarten würde von dem Game.
Es kam jetzt erst vor kurzem die Xbox-Version daraus.
Die läuft mit 20 FPS.
Oh, die haben doch kurz die Werbetrommel gerührt.
Jetzt für Xbox.
Oh, ich kann mal wieder Lucio spielen.
Knautschen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das richtig ausspricht.
Ja, das siehst du mal, was da schon wieder abgeht.
Touch me.
Nein.
Lock mal Dings ein, Reinhard.
Ich denke mit Solo-Support.
Control Center ist das mit der Halle in der Mitte.
Mit diesem runden Ding in der Mitte, wo man schön mit Lucio kreiseln kann.
Jaja, genau das.
Ähm, ne, ich hab noch keinen der neuen Skins.
Weil das ist ja ein recht neuer Account.
Da hab ich noch nicht so viele Lootboxen gekriegt jetzt.
Warum spielst du Smurf-Account?
Ähm, es sieht so aus, aber es ist kein Smurf im eigentlichen Sinne.
Smurf ist für mich jemand, der quasi, keine Ahnung, Master Grandmaster,
oder irgendetwas jetzt einfach mal, die sich in die Noobs bashen will,
auf niedrigerem Rang.
Ich hab's halt diesen drei nicht mehr gespielt.
Und laut internem Matchmaking von Blizzard ist es ja so,
dass ich immer noch Grandmaster-Games gerankt werde mit meinem Main-Account.
Obwohl ich's halt diesen drei nicht gespielt hab.
Und das wollte ich einfach nicht.
Deswegen hab ich mir einen neuen Account gemacht.
Oh, Shield-Spam is real.
Der Shield-Spam is real.
Busted, wrecked.
Und schon down.
Krass, ey.
Okay, ähm, ich...
Nein, Reinhardt funktioniert nicht gegen das grade.
Ja, es wird halt schonmal, wenn du wegsitzt.
Meinst du, wir noch schlimmer?
Ja, ja, das...
Wir müssen die drei Leute da...
Die D.Va ist auch noch weg.
Die könnten wir uns jetzt eigentlich schnappen.
Pass auf, hier liegt ne Falle.
Meine Fresse, ey!
Geht da mal einer!
Please, Leute, please!
Du musst anders raus.
Da können wir nicht langen.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach auf den Spot.
Und stellen uns da hin.
In die Ecke.
Und lassen die Gegner zu uns kommen.
Jetzt sind die postwärts.
Bam, geht doch.
Ich brauch Heal übrigens.
Halt mir das hoch.
Heal, please.
Junko hat es noch links.
Unser Genji ist gut.
Okay, nein, ich nehm's zurück.
Ich nehm's zurück.
Toll.
D.Va ist aus dem Eck raus.
Ja, ein super Rest.
Schild geht weg.
Oh, ich schlafe auch noch.
Jetzt geht's aber ab.
Alter!
J eden, J eden,ид!
Sticky Sticky Sticky, ich brauch Heal
So, Shatter ist am Start. Ich geh jetzt einfach auf den Spot drauf
Gut
Please follow up
Super Charme, ja Leute. Die haben ich ja gefühlt drei Kilometer in die Luft. Tracer ist auf dem Punkt hinter mir
Wenn die Messing nicht reißen kann, dann... Achtung kommt von oben. Ja, reckt
Ja, reckt. Oh, jetzt gehen sie ab. Jetzt kommt der Spawn-Tyre
Okay, ich geh mit vor. Junkrat, Junkrat, Spot, Spot, Junkrat
Junkrat
Gucken, ob da nochmal was kommt jetzt. Ja, Tracer noch dran
Okay, ging doch
Wow, Hanzo ist ein erster Kill, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ja, der hat's, der hat uns gecarried, der Hanzo
Der Hanzo hat es so gemacht, der wollte einfach nicht, dass wir sehen, dass wir gerade so hart von ihm gecarried werden
Deswegen hatte die Gegner immer nur low geschossen, bis auf ein Leben und hat uns die finishing lassen, dass er nicht im Killfeed auftaucht
Weil die beste Eigenschaften eines Hanzo-Mains ist einfach Bescheidenheit
So sind sie alle, so sind sie. Richtige Hanzo-Mains sind einfach die bescheidensten Leute, es gibt...
Die killen nicht selbst, die lassen dich killen, obwohl sie die Arbeit machen
Ich bin gerade mal auf D.Va, also ich hoffe, dass die Leute was treffen, sonst ist...
Lass links lang gehen, nicht über die Brücke, weil wir kennen uns schon
Ich hab hier immer Schiss auf den Punkt mit Reinhard, dass mich da irgendwas runter schmeißt
Also, auf der rechten Seite
Kommst du? Ich bin da, ich bin nicht so schnell
Ich laufe schon so schnell, wie es geht
Ja, schon eine Maker-Baron
Heal please, heal please
Das ist ein richtig guter Triple-Strike
Chop die Anna
Help
What the fuck?
Wo sind denn alle?
Alle down
Ja, genau, versuch einfach noch ein bisschen zu delayen
Die Fahrer, die kickt mich runter, wenn ich da jetzt halt aufpasse
Die ist schon da, die ist schon da
Ist der Konkassen-Slass los?
Du musst rüber, sonst...
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt ist er nicht oben
Da, fuck
Please, Leute, killt was
Jetzt machen wir es
Jetzt geh ich auf off-tank und es wird nichts mehr gekillt
Das ist Palme
Die...
Ach Gott!
Was ist das?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich hab Shatter am Start
Ich hab...
Leute, warum hampeln wir hier rum?
Wir können doch einfach warten
Du musst zurückgehen
Okay
Ich hab auch Shatter
Ich hab Shatter
Start
Rechts, der Roadhog
Okay, die haben keinen Schild
Ich bin da
Nein
Ah, fuuh
Shatter, was ist das?
Loll
Ja, das, Leute, das gefällt euch
Das findet ihr egal
Ich versuch noch irgendwas zu hammern
Shatter, Shatter
Ohohoho
Fett umgeoltet
Ja, das war fair
Das war fair
Ausrufezeichen rank
Das ist eine gute Idee
So was könnte ich mal einführen
oder so
Was ist das hier?
Ach, das mit links und rechts runter
Nee, nee, da spiel ich keinen Roadhog
Wollen wir
D.Va Winston spielen?
Ja, können wir auch machen
Allerdings solo spielen
Ach, fuck
Soll ich
Soll ich Lucian spielen?
Winston, Winston
Nee, wenn wir keinen Tank haben, dann ist das halt alles wieder fürn Arsch
Kekserino, Norserino, wat?
Die Mercy stirbt halt direkt schon
wenn es aus dem Spawn ausläuft
Die gehen on-spot
Die gehen auch on-spot
Pharah fast tot
Ey
Help
Schild hast du bekommen
Ja, das ist aber nicht alles
Da muss halt ein bisschen Druck auf die Gegner sein
Aber das können wir gut
Das packen wir, das packen wir
Winnable
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Roadhog
D.Va und Adam links
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck
Alter, Leute
Gibt's doch nicht
Ein Mord, PogChamp
Halloi
Bist du in der Mitte, bist du da?
Ich bin in der Mitte, ja
Äh, wat?
Moment, wo bin ich jetzt gerade hängen geblieben?
Die kommen oben, die Hälfte ist von innen
Kein Schild mehr?
Fast alle, ja
Ganz schön viele, ganz schön viele
Vorsicht, Tracer
Jetzt müssen wir Kree weg basteln
Skatter
Oh
Wo kommt denn der Senja?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, der hat mich hardcore gereckt
Pass auf von Main
M1 Simulator
Das gibt's nicht
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Ich bin gerade rausgehöpft und werde echt verreckt
Nice, easy win, easy clap
Meine Güte, ey, das ist so anstrengend, wenn du bloß einen im Team hast, der
Kacke pickt
Jetzt überleg dir mal, wie anstrengend das erst ist
Ich weiß nicht, was hast du überlegt, du hast ja gestern wieder selbst gemerkt
Wenn du alleine spielst
Bam, jawoll
Die Chillmusik ist mir da gerade zu chillig, ich muss da mal etwas anderes anmachen
So was
Moin Raffi
Ja, noch 152 Punkte und dann ist GM angesagt
Ja, ich hab jetzt 3.709
Ganz cool
Max, hast du den Skandal um Dr. Disrespect mitbekommen?
Nein, ich verfolge ihn nicht
Jax, hast du den mitbekommen? Du guckst das ja öfters
Ja, ab und zu gucke ich aber in der letzten Zeit auch nicht
Was denn Blackfire, was gibt es denn da für einen Skandal um Dr. Disrespect?
Z Pro, ich mach wahrscheinlich eins, ja, aber das muss ordentlich vorbereitet sein, deswegen kann es ein bisschen dauern
Darf ich mal wieder, vielleicht darf ich ja mal anders spielen oder so
Da musst du aber schnell einloggen, damit die Leute ein bisschen
Haben wir Mercy mains, mal schauen
Ich weiß, wer Mercy spielen darf
Du kannst auch Lucian spielen, also wenn von denen auch eine Mercy nimmst
Moira
Komm, ich nehm Mercy, scheiße, da ist drauf
Komm jetzt wieder, bin ich ja schon mittlerweile bekannt hier für
Vorhin hat jemand geschrieben, er kommt nur ins Stream wegen Mercy Plays
Was, Karottkuchen?
Blackfire sagt, Dr. Disrespect hat im Stream erzählt, dass er seine Frau betrogen hat
Ich weiß nicht, wie ernst man das bei ihm nehmen kann
Wie gesagt, ich verfolge das nicht, aber was ich am Rande gesehen habe, ist da noch sehr viel Getrolle dabei
Ist das ernst zu nehmen, ja, wie gesagt, ich hab's nicht verfolgt
Erinnert mich an die 8 Inches Geschichte mit Dings Visa, Kevri
8 Inches
Oh, hier ist ein Genji oben
Damage Boost, der kommt von hinten gleich, der Genji
Hinter uns ist er
Ich bin auf dir drauf
Ich muss abhauen
Ich kann nicht zurück
Jetzt komm ich wieder vor
Genji ist auf mir drauf
Alter, das gibt's doch nicht
Vorne war alles safe und jetzt ist auf einmal hinter uns alles zusammengebrochen
Ich muss zurücklaufen
Keine Zeit
Ja, Reinhardt, du niedest kein Healing
Wenn du Healing nieden würdest, dann würdest du zurückkommen
Oder die Meurer könnte ich auch mal heilen
Ja, das ist mega die Action gerade, ich probier's jetzt noch einmal mit Wetterung
Ich glaub, die wollen gebashed werden
Ich werd geschlitzt
Ich hab null Unterstützung, das ist übelst räudisch
Weder der Reinhardt noch der Rotor noch irgendjemand interessiert sich dafür
Ja, ich wüsste schon
Das Team fällt auseinander wie sonst was
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Battlefield 4 gespielt, ein bisschen her?
Ja oder so
Can you guys come in voice, ja ich komm mal in voice, dass er nicht gleich los tiltet
Aber daran liegt es nicht wirklich
Ich bin weit, ich bin auf dir
Und Anna, wir können jetzt
Wie wird das Ding durchgepusht?
Müssen wir, der Genji ist noch Serverraum
Nope
Moment, mein Rätsel verschwindet, wenn mich einer wegkickt beim Rätseln?
Was ist das denn?
Mercy sick, Mercy gameplay intense
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß
Beste
Ich bleib mal bei dir
Damage plus
Die sind alle oben links und ein paar rechts, wie auch immer das Ding heißt
Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten ein Soldier
Der hat es auf mich abgesehen
Bleib bei mir
Nein, ich muss weg, ich muss weg
Ich bin bei dir
Diese Heilung man
Huge Mercy Plays Chat
Ich bin übrigens in Voice Chat, es sagt keiner was
Beste
Bleib wieder alt
Ich versuche mal zu dir zu kommen
Da kommt gleich ein Münzen auf dich
Schreckt
Sushi Chef am Berg
Ja, huge geschlitzt
Das Problem ist, so wirklich durchpushen können wir nicht
Wenn wir hier uns so einen Upstaggeren
Ich mach gleich Ulti an, wenn alle wieder da sind
Nice
Oh, sick, sick Helix auf mich in der Luft
Ich kann dich nicht heilen, ich bin tot
Nice, nice, nice Pick, brauchst du Heal, ich gucke gerade nicht nach hinten
Über uns, Soldier, über uns, über uns
Hier, hier hoch
Ok, ich komm zu dir dann
Sollte dann, ich bin oben
Warum ist das Kackding jetzt nicht geflogen
Nein, hinter dir
Roadhog, Roadhog kommt zurück
Diese Mercy Hitboxen, die sind zum Kotzen
Ich verpiss mich, sofern es geht
Ok, ich hab jetzt Ulti, die haben ihre Ulti raus
Das passt, da können wir jetzt fett draufputschen noch
Pushen
Wenn sie nicht verrecken Leute, Leute nicht hier
Ok, das ist mehr oder weniger der letzte Push
Ich muss mich verstecken, ich bin fast down
Ich bin auch fast down, kannst du mich heilen hinter dir
Oh, what
Genji ist oben auf der Brücke
Ich geh mal hoch
Genji ist auf mir drauf, oh, geschlitzt
Huge kills, huge kills
Ich komm mit Lucio wieder, wird schneller da
Nice
Oh, ich hab mein Headset-Verstärkungsding runter geschmissen
Warte mal
Das passiert, wenn man hängen bleibt mit dem Stuhl am Kabel
Ich muss das danach mal fixen
Ah, jetzt gehts, jetzt soll ich wieder auf beiden Seiten
Perfekt
Ja, ich sehe es komisch, ich muss Mercy spielen
Das wäre geil, wenn wir einen Zenyatta hätten
Ich würde Zen spielen, wenn wir eine Mercy hätten
Aber Zen ist nicht so das
Weil das kann man bestimmt gut koordiniert machen
Da ist halt damage overkill
Gehts richtig ab, fetzt alles weg
Ich hätte halt gerne Mercy Zen, weil man sonst einfach zu wenig Damage hat
Ja, Mercy Zen ist ja quasi Meta-Support-Duo aktuell, wenn man so guckt
Max ist doch top Mercy EU, ganz klar
Ich finde momentan haben die Supporter einfach viel zu viel Heilung
Und dann kriegst du die Gegner auch nicht platt
Wenn du da nicht 10 Headshots am Stück triffst
Es ist halt so komisch verteilt, du hast so Helden, die dich instant platzen lassen wie Junkrat
Und du hast Sachen, als Winston lutscht zu 3000 eigentlich unendlich an einem Gegner
Kriegt sie nicht richtig tot, weil er geheilt wird
Ich bleib mal hier versteckt
Genji, Genji und Mercy in der Mitte
Lol, Headshot
Skatter, Skatter, Skatter, Skatter, Simple Geometry
Skatter
Och man
Noch ein Headshot
Links ist die Meurer tot, pass auf unten Genji
Der Genji ist übrigens auf mir, ich hab Schiss
Ich muss runter
Muss ich nicht, muss ich nicht, muss ich nicht
Sonnet, ey, fuck
Alter
Mercy
Der Strahl, Genji, Genji, linke Seite
Riep
Oh, der Winston ist slow
Der Genji ist im Serverraum
Der hat gleich Ulti, der hat gleich Ulti
Ich bin nicht bei dir, ich muss, ich bin in der Mitte
Kannst du mich hochfliegen lassen?
Kommst du da weg?
Ich geh jetzt zu dir hoch und
Damage booste dich
Er wird mir schon gebusht, ja
Runter
Fuck ey
Boah, geschletzt, krass geschletzt, oder?
Ja, standen alle im Chokepoint drinne
Huge Mercy Place
Aber dafür haben sie viele Ultis los
War das nicht nur eine?
Wir können das, wir können das
Nee, die Soldier haben sie, Soldier haben sie
Zwei, zwei
Also wir könnten nur Contesten
Ja, wollen wir nicht, wollen wir nicht
Jetzt zurück
Ja
Ich fühle mich hier so ein bisschen unwohl
Jutsch
Komm auf, ne
Ja
Ich komm gleich zu dir geflogen, wenn das hier zu heiß wird unten
Max streamt auf Twitch? Ja, seit einer Weile schon
Leute
Bei uns, ich hab ne D.Va am Arsch
Ich bin schon dran
Ich brauch Heilung
Lieber meint
Jetzt
Damage Boost
Ich flieg zu dir hoch, wenn du da bist
Leute, wir müssen, es gibt halt keinen Grund großartig vor die Türen zu pushen, wenn man nicht quasi da drei, vier Reste aufräumen will
Ich bin oben
Ah, sie ist
Ich versteck mich, ich versteck mich
Ich bin oben down auf dem Schiff, wenn du mich anfliegen kannst
Ach, da warst ein Reck fest
Richtig hardcore Gerecke
Rectangle
Jetzt haben sie nen Reinhard
Linke Seite
Ich hab Genji auf mir
Soldier oben
Kannst du mich anfliegen?
Oh, oh
Ja
Soldier wieder oben
F*** down
Ich hab so viel gerätzt wie ging
Die Zeit ist okay
Wir können das auf jeden Fall nochmal easy contesten
Sag mal, Max, spielst du auch nochmal Battlefield 3?
Ja, stimmt
Ich bin da
Schnell, schnell, ich muss denen helfen, gleich oben
Ich werd geschlitzt
Super, super ey
Wieso pushen die denn nicht?
Kein Bock, roll dich
Pushen, overrated
Was für ein Failplay
Das ist mega ein Failplay von der Moira
Au
Och man
Zurück ins spawn
Wir räumen uns sonst auf
Pass auf
Müssen aufpassen, ob der Earthshatter hat
Hast du geguckt, wann der das letzte Mal geshattert hat?
Weißt du, hast du ungefähr...
Ich hab's alles gesehen
Da flieg ich garantiert nicht rein, um dich zu retzen, Genji
Ich flieg zu dir hoch
Wieder oben
Dauert nicht lang, das ist der Genji
Ich bin wieder unten
Hallo
Ich hab wieder ulti
Geh wieder hoch
Ja, das klingt ganz gut
Der Genji dascht garantiert jetzt hoch, dann flieg ich wieder runter
Er ist zumindest beschäftigt
Er will sicher nicht seinen Keks abrunden
Ja, wahrscheinlich
Jetzt musst du glaube ich rüberfliegen
Letzter Fight
Ich bin down
Fuck, ich bin halt auch verreckt
Jetzt kommen die Overtime, wir können natürlich nicht mehr spawnen
Ich komm als Lucio, ich warte auf dich und dann bringe ich Reinhard mit rein
Du bist raus
Ich bin dran
Der Reinhard ist fast tot
Fuck, an der Brücke oben
Overtime
Dreck
Wie sie sich selbst feiern
So genau wie wir den letzten Teamfight verloren haben, habe ich nicht verstanden
Ich bin in dem Ulti-Gewitter untergegangen, aber eigentlich hätten wir den haben müssen
Den letzten Teamfight
Wenn wir halt nicht im Ulti-Gewitter gestorben werden
Bei wieviel SR sind wir momentan?
Wir sind bei 3.709
Und ich muss immer noch Mercy spielen, weil die Mercy-Mains schon alle High-Crant-Master sind
Allerdings letztes Game hatten wir einen 46 Stunden Mercy
Dafür hat er relativ wenig gemacht, oder?
Für 46 Stunden Mercy
20 Euro, wenn du bis Ende des Streams GM bist
Recht unwahrscheinlich
Aber ich kann ja nicht verlieren, entweder kriege ich 20 Euro oder nicht
Die habe ich ja auch so nicht
Übrigens sagt dem Voice Chat keiner was
Auch wenn man Voice Chat kommen soll
Hinterher, Genji
Also ich fahre weg
Nicht
Wenn der Bastion sich halb mal umdrehen würde, der ist halb auf Carmen
Ich kann mich nicht bewegen hier
Aber dank Overtime, bzw. kein Overtime, spawnen sie jetzt schon relativ schnell
Das heißt wir können noch was bashen da
Oben ist ein Genji, oben links
Der könnte Oldclay haben
Jetzt darf er am Ball gestorben
Was ist das hier für ein Ding ey
Oh, oh
Ich versuche zu dir zu kommen
Gehst du wieder runter?
Ja, ich bin so halbe halbe halbe
Der Rein hat keinen Earth Shatter da drauf
Die können nicht mehr alle so weit von Oldclay weg sein
Ach komm ey
Fuck
Aber sind ganz gut
Also wir sind relativ weit gekommen
In der Minute
Ich bin zwar mit Old gestorben, aber das hätte es nicht geressen
Ich hätte den Soldier killen können, aber manchmal
Moment, Bastion, Defense fallen dich wenig von
Ich finde man ist da oben, wenn man Highcorn steht fast schon zu weit weg
Um effektiv Damage machen zu können
Außer wenn die halt gerade die Ecke an dir vorbeifahren
Immer wenn ich Mercy spiele
Ich fange an, wenn ich Mercy spiele
Ich weiß nicht, ob Divecombe so sinnvoll ist mit einer Moira
Ich zeige euch total für den Arsch
Mein Game plinkt
Heute sieht man das auch im Stream
Na jetzt gehts
Die Divecombe mit Moira ist, naja, die muss mit Dive
Die muss mit Dive Moira
Das Problem ist, der fährt halt nix um
Chat, habt ihr verstanden, was er gerade gesagt hat?
Was will er? Ich verstehs nicht
Jetzt sagst du schon wieder All voice, please
Der hat doch noch nie gesprochen
Doch, er hat gerade irgendwas gesagt, ich soll nicht nur dich boosten oder so
Hast du ja nicht
Mach ich auch nicht
Ich bin bei dir
Ok, runter, runter, trocken
Das kannst du vergessen
Divecombe ist für den Arsch
Ja, das sagt
Ok, zurück, regroupen
Regroupen, regroupen, regroupen, regroupen
Die pushen
Also ich geh jetzt rein, Yolo
Ja, Yolo, Yolo style
Die anderen gehen nicht hin, ok
Die haben keinen Bock
Das war ja der unkoordinierteste Kack aller Zeiten
Orisa? Ach jetzt, weil er jetzt Bastion hat
Wir haben doch schon Weihard
Ja super, die Tracer stirbt halt 10 Jahre spät
Ist das zum kotzen
Ok, ok, wir können die jetzt noch richtig gut einmal ordentlich weiten und gut ist
Was machen die denn da oben?
Ja, Soldier geht nicht da und wir verrecken
Genji
Das ist einfach Fail gewesen, oder?
Ich krieg den nicht down
Krasser Fail
Selbst mit Ulti, mit Genji Blade kriegst du den nicht down ohne Discord ab, ist verschissen
Ah, ist echt Fail
Ok, ich zieh raus
Flawless Dream ist vorbei Leute
Das war total unkoordiniert
Erst oben, dann irgendwie komischer Fight am Punkt
Total weird
I don't know
Aber Dive Combo ohne Zen, das ist halt brain fucked
Das ist halt Platin Niveau
Also keine Ahnung
So, mal gucken ob ich irgendwas im Chat überlesen hab
Bei wie viel SR habe ich glaube schon gezeigt
Jetzt sind wir wieder, wir sind gedroppt, Game verloren
Gleich mal fette 28 Punkte runter
Aber wir können nicht alles gewinnen, gestern haben wir komplett alles gerockt
Flawless 8-0, easy, easy clap, wrecked, Tyrannosaurus wrecked, schrecked
Alles zusammen gestern, das war ja, ich glaub so viel in Folge haben wir schon nie gewonnen
Was arbeitest du?
Ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um unsere Softwareverwaltung
Repo-Management
Source-Code, Repo-Management
Ja, Sam Fischer, Moira
Moira ist so langsam aber sicher
Ich guck mir ja auch immer wieder an
Ich guck mir auch immer wieder an
Wenn ich Zeit hab, die Pro-Streams an
Moira scheint da ziemlich stark im Kommen zu sein
Wenn man sich anschaut
Wie viele die zur Zeit üben
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wenn
Moira überhaupt nicht viable wäre
Moira überhaupt nicht viable wäre in Pro-Matches
Dass dann so viele Pro-Streams in ihrem Stream
so hard practisen wie man das zur Zeit sieht
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Halloburger
Magst nichts gegen dich aber hör auf zu stehen
Ja wenn du das sagst
Lass mich überlegen
Da hab ich doch gar nicht dran gedacht
Gut, dass du mir das gesagt hast
Was ist mit Dr. Kabum passiert? Nichts, was soll mit ihm passiert sein? Also dem geht es gut
Dem geht es gut
Dann macht man mehr Videos, vor allem noch mehr, ne? Aber bei der Gelegenheit kann ich ja gerade mal auf YouTube reingucken
Das überfordert mich immer Multitasking technisch zu streamen, zu gucken hier in-game, Chat, Twitch plus ab und zu mal auf YouTube rein, das ist einfach zu, das schafft mein 33-jähriges Gehirn nicht mehr
So, wieder da, kann es Q'en
Ja, Z Pro, so ist es, ne? Er hat uns die Augen geöffnet
Er hat uns die Augen geöffnet. Also Jax, wir müssen jetzt leider den Stream beenden, weil einer im Chat hat gesagt, ich soll aufhören
Ich hab's vorher einfach nicht vermutlich gehalten, aber jetzt sehe ich's
What the fuck?
Ich Q'e
Wie geht's dem Friseur, dem geht's auch gut, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Friseur, Ausrufezeichen Fabian, Ausrufezeichen Frizi, eins dieser Kommandos, ich glaub Ausrufezeichen Fabian ist es
Er ist auch auf Twitch aktiv und streamt ziemlich viel Black Desert Online, das ist ein MMO und crymets sich da den ganzen Tag
Aber er streamt aktuell sogar, seh ich grade, er streamt aktuell. Wollen wir D.Va Winston Action machen?
Ne, nicht mit den Heilern, sag ich dir ehrlich
Nein wollen wir nicht, hast du recht
Ich verschaffe mal ein bisschen Self-Heal
Ja, ich nehm da Maisel
Moin Pizzi, ne Pazzi
Können die mal aufhören mit ihrer scheiß Moira
Die stehen da voll drauf
Ey es ist Practice und ganz viele Pros zurzeit Moira wenn man sich Streams aufverfolgt
Da ist was im Busch, da ist was im Busch, ich sag's dir, Moira hat demnächst Hardcore-Meter und ohne Moira Must-Have geht nix
Ich seh's zwar auch noch nicht
Guck mal die Orissas sind keine Physikobjekte hier im Startbereich
Ich bin enttäuscht Blizzard
Oh man ey, das ist so ein schimmliges Teamsetup
Nohawk, nohawk, okay, okay
Was dann?
Komm ich muss beschreiben
Du musst beschreiben, no heal
5, 4, 3, 2, 1
Komm ich mach mal dass er gleich nicht los tiltet
Nicht weil ich es besonders sinnvoll halte da als für das andere zu spielen
Aber ich will nicht dass er gleich los tiltet, du kennst die Leute
Guck ich bin übrigens low die ganze Zeit
Nice, nice, nice, nice
Ich geh rein, ich geh rein, ich geh rein
Zen hinter uns, hinter uns, Zen
Geflanktes Wod
Das letzte Ulti
Ja, warum hatte die bitteschön schon
Alter, warum hatte die das überlebt so lange
Da, da weißt du schon warum
Oh jetzt haben wir eine Ana, jetzt wird alles besser
Das war eine schnelle Fahrer Ulti, ja
Das war außergewöhnlich schnell
So schnell geht das eigentlich dann
Wir können auch nicht durch die Chalkbahn durch, weil wir keine D-Fahrer haben
Das ist ein Schuss
Ich will hier auch nicht durch, aber was
Ich hab es so echt
Ich bin übrigens fast down
Das wird wieder was
Jetzt könnte man wenigstens halb mal die Mäurer erpressen
Wenn man eine Mäurer sie hätte
Oh das ist so fail
Was sind die denn alle
Na, wollen alle durch den Tunnel oben durch
Oh
I don't know
Das ist zum verlieren verurteilt
Das ist wieder Wahnsinn ey
Aber wir können nicht jeden Tag alles gewinnen
Ja, aber das sind die Matches, die wieder traurig sind bis zum geht nicht
Warum wollen die unbedingt da oben durch
Komm wir flanken jetzt außen links lang
In der Mitte ist ein Winston
Ja dann komm raus
Komm zu
Die sind jetzt scheinbar schon oben
Hinter uns ein Winston
Das ist mega
Oh huge
Ich kriege aber halt keinen Heal
Die nächste Fahrhaut
Ne, mit Dreier klappt das nicht
Das funktioniert nicht
Ich kriege noch nicht mal Charge
Also ich kriege noch nicht mal Ultimate gescheit
Ich nehme jetzt irgendwas anderes
Winston, komm
Sollen wir uns noch mal einen Smurf machen
Damit wir wieder fähige Teammates haben
Das ist halt einfach Pech
Komm wir haben so gerockt die letzten Tage
Darum ist ja gar nichts
Leute wo sollt ihr denn
Help
Ich habe keine Ahnung was hier abgeht
Was ist max sein Career High
Ich glaube auf Main war das höchste mal irgendwie 3900
Hinter euch eine Fahrrad
Komm die wird jetzt gebashed
Nein
Oh Mann ey
Das ist ja wieder eine absolut verkackte Scheißrunde
Oh huge
Ach komm
Der ist tot
Schwere Geburt
Echt schwere Geburt
Wahnsinn
Ich habe eine Meurer Kugel angeflogen
Wat
Ja ist ja gut
Ich glaube du bist ein bisschen Yolo
Ich war ein bisschen sehr Yolo
Und habe das Schild an die falsche Stelle gesetzt
Aber die sollen ruhig Ults raushauen
Haut Ults raus Leute
Haut alles raus
Komm einfach durch
Ich habe Ults hier
Jetzt kommt der Spawn
Der Winston ist über uns
Okay auch mal hoch
Winston lebt hinten
Ich kriege die anderen weg
Mach den Tot
Warum kriege ich Nanoboost
Fahrer über euch
Ja super Zen Ulti
Fuck Off
Farhriebei ist
Da ist ein paar Zen Ultis.. oh fuck!
die gegner sind nicht mal gut so was die haben voll das schlechte movement und alles
da kann ich ein bisschen minsten üben, das ist gut ok minsten ist weg
helb leute helb, ich nehme aus die am arsch der welt
ist minsten das f? nein ist das der wissenschaftler
das ist kyentist ok ich wreck oh f?
gehst du rein ich komme ich bin dran
super die kriegen wir die kriegen wir
wo ist die fahrer fast down geht in spawn rein
schaub sie
das war auf den letzten drücker
minsten macht übelst bock den muss ich auf jeden fall mal üben ich merke das noch ich
kann es so überhaupt nicht richtig einschätzen so mit mit mit winkel wie du springen musst
jetzt macht er dir noch spaß warte mal bis du richtig gute gegner triffst und dann fackt
du ab ja komm aber wenn die mit fahrer ankommen
da wieder minsten minsten
huge win nice nice noch ist ja kein win ich frage mich halt echt ob sich das youtube nicht
anders vorgestellt hat dass man diese community funktion als stream werbung für twitch verwendet
so geil das einzige was ich gepostet habe bisher da drauf ist stream live stream live
bin wieder live auf twitch stream live das haben die sich garantiert nicht so vorgestellt
und heute warte schon im neuen star wars film
ich bin jetzt mal ganz ketzerisch und sage ich werde ihn mir nicht angucken weil ich
kein star wars fan bin stream auf youtube ja ganz bestimmt hast du tipps um aus gold
rauszukommen ja viel spielen erstmal das ist eigentlich der wichtigste tipp viel spielen
und sich selbst eingestehen wenn man misst gebaut hat
es kommt ein bisschen was die posten rechts durch wenn wir da rein springen ja ja ja ja
ich habe meine die flaketurne wo ich hinter den gegner stammt und ich bin gegen schild
gesprungen wie der letzte kacknup
wir können das noch ein bisschen kontesten
ich gehe gleich über ey
ob es das autonoma und
uns fuk fack fack das war jetzt zu viele zu langsam gestorben
gleich ulti
twilson ist erst, jetzt bin ich zum ersten mal auf dass es eigentlich wichtig ist zu wissen wo so
kleine hindernisse auf der map sind, ich bleibs immer dran hängen
ich glaube die fahrer ist oben links drinnen, ich bin nur nicht da
oh, der ist weg, können wir pushen? ja
hinter uns wird noch gerätzt
da ist nur ne fahrer
da ist масси масси масси масси масси масси масси масси масси inspections
soldiers
oder auch nicht
Ich bin so ne? Ich auch, ich bin auch drin.
Wohohoho, das haben sie uns aber geschnetzelt.
Ich hab auch eine gute Zeit rausgeholt.
Äh, Dings Feier wird auf dem Highground sein.
Ich geh hoch.
Kommst du mit?
Ja.
Oder wir können noch mal die Payload.
Jaja, wir kontesten.
Ok, dann raus.
Ach komm, ein HP.
Oh mann, ich wollt grad Melee drücken.
Wo sind unsere Huge Rasses?
Huge Rasses.
Wir müssen an der Payload bleiben.
Du hast die links.
Oh Leute.
Leute, der Fiddle von Summerfat hier Ulti-Spann.
Das wäre nice.
So muss das sein.
Ein paar Tipps, wie man es sich mit HTMN und CSS leichter tut.
Äh, fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Ich find's an sich.
Einfach dran gewöhnen.
Ja, da ist aber noch nichts da.
In der Mitte.
In der Mitte? Ich hab ein Schild gesetzt.
Er ist verloren.
Ich hab grad noch Schild gesetzt.
Alles angefangen mit dem Roadhog.
Weil er so super ulti reingeht.
Wilson-Ult fühl ich mich komplett unfähig noch mit.
Weil wir ein bisschen hin und her schubsen, ist es ja nicht getan.
Können wir? Ich hab Blade.
Ja, ich hab Schild, drei, zwei, eins.
Der Roadhog, was geht mit dem ab?
Ich spiel jetzt mal eine D.Va.
Mercy, wo bist du denn?
Mercy!
WTF?
Mercy, WTF, was war das denn?
Meine Güte, ey.
Trotz Nano-Blade, zack, down.
Oh, was war das für ein Scheiß-Blade.
Die Winston-Blades waren auch nicht gut.
Aber was hat...
Was denken wir denn sich dabei?
So, jetzt kein Winston.
Ich spiel jetzt Roadhog.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich verreck sonst eh.
Kann ich mich wenigstens selbst halten.
Jetzt haben wir wieder dasselbe Problem-Setup wieder vor.
Ja, bloß diesmal Roadhog statt Reinhardt.
Und Dubino, das kann schon gut funktionieren.
Stimmt, nur Orissa wäre nicht verkehrt mit dem Turret.
Ich würde Orissa gehen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schaffe rechtzeitig.
Lucio pick me up.
Das kann ich nicht rechtzeitig.
Lucio ist auch wieder komplett brain af, Leute.
Wo steht denn der Turret, kannst du mir das sagen?
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Da steht noch gar keiner, scheinbar.
Ich schieß mal was zu dir hoch.
Wir sind Mitte.
Die daiflen dich hardcore.
Soldier, down.
Mercy down, Mercy ist weg.
Help, Leute, please.
Schon vorbei.
Zwei Leute gekillt inklusive Mercy, das kann doch nicht sein.
Ach Gott.
Was ein Game.
Wir haben den Gegner gut gemacht, so sieht eine Life Combo aus.
Legs mit flawless winning stream.
Ich kann es queueen.
Ich kann queueen?
Jedes Season wird schlimmer.
Jawohl Blizzard.
Man kann ja nur beschränkt den Leuten einen Vorwurf machen, finde ich.
Zwar auch, ja.
Aber Blizzard muss das auch ordentlich umsetzen.
Ich meine, seit Season 2 oder so hat sich ja an der Sache nichts geändert.
Ich meine, wenn ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass von Anfang an über das Rankingsystem geflamed wurde.
Und jetzt kommen sie auf die Idee, Performance-based Matchmaking ist keine so gute Idee.
So.
Hab ich irgendwas überlesen im Chat?
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Ach so, ja, noch was zum Thema.
Bist du noch da?
Dot polarized?
Ja, du bist noch da, aber schreibst ja grad was.
Also zur HTML und CSS.
Das Einzige, was mir einfällt, was man machen kann, dass man ein bisschen leichter fällt, ist,
nicht in der Datei rumeditieren, reloaden und gucken,
sondern die Zeiten zwischen editieren und Anzeigen möglichst kurz zu machen.
Entweder indem du im Browser selbst, in den Browser Entwicklungstools selbst ein bisschen rumprobierst,
also direkt siehst, wie sich was auswirkt, was du machst auf der Seite.
Kannst ja auch direkt im Browser editieren.
Oder du kannst einen Editor verwenden, der sich quasi mit dem Browser connectet.
Du schreibst was live im Editor und das ändert sich auf der Seite.
Oder wenn das nicht geht, nimmst du irgendeinen Live Reload Plugin,
dass du quasi bei jedem Mal speichern, dass du automatisch den Browser reloadest.
Da musst du nicht jedes Mal den Browser anklicken, R5 drücken und so.
Das ist nervig.
Werden Helden beim Balancing immer geschwächt?
Die würden irgendwann keinen Damage mehr machen.
Nee, wenn du dir Junkrat anguckst, Junkrat wurde nicht geschwächt.
Junkrat wurde OP gebufft.
Das hat angefangen mit zwei Minen, glaube ich, oder?
Mhm.
Genau, zwei Minen.
Dann irgendwann, dass er immun war gegen Damage.
Ich glaube, das war nicht der gleiche Patch.
Beide habe ich nicht gespielt in der Zeit.
Das habe ich nur so auf Reddit verfolgt.
Ja.
Kannst du dich noch an das Taschentuch-Tire erinnern aus der Beta?
Angehustet und weg?
Taschentuch-Tire?
Das Tire vom Junkrat war, als es nur 25 oder 50 TP hatte, kurzzeitig.
Da hast du wirklich, das hast du angespuckt, das war kaputt.
Das war noch nice.
Ja, Beta habe ich nicht gezogen.
Moment.
Jetzt geht es halt schon wieder los mit diesen...
Das hasse ich.
Moment.
So, Abblade-Master kannst du die ganzen Spieler einfach in die Tonne klopfen.
Ja, und ich soll jetzt denken, oder was?
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Nee, komm, wir machen jetzt Tank-Action.
Wollen wir, wollen wir Dive-Tank-Action machen?
Oder wollen wir, nee, wir machen mal wieder die Reinhardt.
Reinhardt und D.Va-Kombi oder sowas.
Wobei, du hast halt nicht gescheit, wir haben nicht gescheit healed.
Oder du zumindest nicht, wenn du reingehst.
Ja, eigentlich habe ich ja überhaupt keinen heal mit den zwei Sportern.
So.
Kannst du knicken, ich probiere es mit.
Hallo Lars.
Escape.
Aber mit Speed ist es schon immer angenehm.
Ich muss poschen.
Alle slow, aber nichts stirbt.
Genji auf mir.
D.Va ist auch noch.
Genji ist hinter uns, ich push weiter.
Genji ist rechts hinter dir im Gang.
D.Va fast tot.
Tab.
Demnächst Ulti.
Erstes Team, den du siehst.
Ja, aktuell bin ich ziemlich viel am streben.
Wo sind auf einmal alle hin?
Alle verreckt.
Habe ich am Ulti.
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen sehr Yolo-Style gerade.
Die Genji ist durch mich durchgedashed.
War hinter mir, ich habe im Headshot gegeben.
Ich muss die Karte anpassen.
Parampel.
Ich schatter die jetzt gleich so krass.
Gut, chatter.
Du bist erstaunt.
Dieser Moment, wo du nach oben Grappling Hook machst und eine D.Va Ulti auf den Gesicht fliegt.
Perfekt
Scheiß drauf, ich mach jetzt Mehlereinhard
Nein
Help
Nice
Wir haben ganz gute Picks, ich muss wieder Voller offen
Max, wann kommt eigentlich Subbutton? Hab ich mich noch nicht darum gekümmert
Let´s break it down
Easy
Kommt gleich noch mal was
Max vollzeit streamer, ja ich hab Urlaub, da geht das auch
Auto, fahre
Nice Picks
Ach Leute, ich dachte das ist zu euch rüber geflogen
Es war auch bei uns drüben, aber auch High Crown, alle zerbärstet
Ja ja, lasst die alle schön Ultis verschwenden
Lasst die alle schön Ultis verschwenden
Jutsch
Kack Mercy
Ich pushe, Jutsch Chatter Leute
Rechts Mercy, rechts
Jutsch
Mercy links
Nice, da wird durchgehämmert
Die Cap finde ich total bescheuert
Braucht man nicht
So, die filmen sie ja, da bleibt man nicht viel anderer so brisch
Sam Fischer, den gucke ich auch gern
Vor allem mit seinem komischen Voice-to-Text-to-Speech
Das finde ich lustig, das war eine Abwechslung
Außer bei Scream-Grills, da kann es auch Boop-Camp statt Face-Camp geben und die Leute finden es geil
Willst du wieder Ecke contesten?
Oder willst du, ah nee du bist Widow
Ne wahrscheinlich willst du überhaupt nicht obendrauf contesten
Eher weniger
Hi Mercy, sag denen doch, dass unser Setup ist
What the fuck
Moin Defi
Die Mercy hat mich lieb gewonnen, sie boostet mich
Nice, jetzt geht es ab
Machs, machs, fertig
Haha, Evoli
Ja, hab ich, lass es nochmal von jemand anderem angucken
Ich bleib mal hier drauf stehen, wenn du irgendwie Hilfe brauchst in der Nähe sag Bescheid
Nice, echt
Hat wieder gerätzt
Schild geht gleich kaputt
Ich geh jetzt runter contesten, Schild geht kaputt
Bum, Bum, Big Shack
Die haben auch ne Widow jetzt am Start
Widow ist oben in der Mitte
Hopp, hüpft drauf
Genji ist im Base
Nice
Winston oben
Wir sollten nicht so sehr contesten in der Mitte
Die Widow hat freie Sicht da von diesem LKM
Zug oder was das sein soll
Wo ist der Tracer hinten
Tracer in euch drin
Widow ist in der Mitte, ich lasse Schild oben
Wir müssen mal verrecken, wie gerade alle
Ja, Winston auf mir, ey
Wir können das noch halten
Widow ist hinter euch
Ich hab die Mercy gleich
Huge
Nicht huge, viele erwischt, aber kein Follow up, war schon alles tot
Die Widow macht gerade Spawn Rape
Das ist auch ein absoluter Fail von mir, dass ich nicht geguckt hab, wie viele Leute noch leben
Ich find's aber auch schwierig als Tank einen Überblick zu behalten, gehen wir ran
Widow in der Mitte
Ich bin am contesten
Ich hab da was
Widow in der Mitte
Ich bleib gleich in der Mitte stehen mit dem Schild
Pass auf, nichts hinein
Ich bekomm keinen Freiraum mehr, sonst ist es zum Katzen
Widow ist in der Tankstelle unten
Die sind aber so geil auf mich ey
Ich hab mich hier gefühlt dreimal über die ganze Map gekickt
Gute Zeit, gute Zeit
Ulti gefarmt
Zurückkommen, zurück
Mach dein Schild hoch, weil die haben Ulti
Er ist schon am Start
Linke Seite oben
Ist wieder runter
Tracer hinter uns, fang an zu hammern
Ein Hit
Geht rechts durch
Wenn der Münzen Schild raus hat wird
Wie viele leben noch genug?
Keine Ahnung
Ich glaube nicht
Wird alles weggehammern, irgendwas war noch hinter uns
Ich glaube ich hab oben im Gang was gehört
Oben links im Gang
Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe
Die Divers nicht im Auto drin, die können wir erst mal so lassen
Die sind oben drauf, ich muss jetzt auch hoch
Tracer hüpft auch noch unten rum
Fast tot
Sniper
Noch Mercy, komm an
One hack
Ich brauch Hilfe
CTF
Allzeit ist gut
Jetzt kannst du knicken
Top
Was, wieso bin ich jetzt im Metra, WTF
Nee bist du nicht
Ach du hast geschwitzt, WTF
Was war das denn
Tracer, komm an
Schlimme ist halt, gegnerische Widow hat frei rum, das Tod ist, ich hab gar keinen
Genji wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt
Komm mal ein bisschen zurück
Die sind alle drin bei uns oben jetzt
Huge
Ach man, warum aufextenden die immer so des Todes
Ich will jetzt hier nicht feiten in Unterzahl
Kannst du ein bisschen zurück kommen
Aber unsere Zarya geht dran
Wird gefressen ne
Ich bin gestackt
Hilfe
Alter
Also einmal noch regroupen und dann
Einmal regroupen, ich hab halt schön rausgeschaddert
Ist gestorben
Das links Haus
Warte noch
Jetzt raus
Die gehen natürlich rechts raus für die Bots
C9
Daimler season please
Also der Anfang von dem Game war richtig geil
Aber die haben es auch gut gemacht, also der Widowpick hat uns wirklich ziemlich Probleme bereitet
Vielleicht wäre es auch besser gewesen, wir hätten, wobei wir hatten einen Winston, oder?
Hatten wir einen Winston?
Nee wir hatten keinen Winston
Zumindest hatten wir ihn kaum gesehen
Also wenn irgendwie einer noch Genji Winston gepickt hätte, einfach um die Widow mehr zu ficken
Ich bin nur kurz 3 Minuten, Havka
Ja, guck mal, Kronen chat
Ich gucke mal in die Follows rein, was es da so neues gibt
Oh danke für die Follows
Ich kann leider noch die letzten vorlesen, weil mehr sehe ich nicht
Danach sehe ich dann wieder nur vor 3 Tagen
TheLeggingMoritzMaschkunzDSRTVPR712
Also muss ich sagen, linguistisch der beste Name des heutigen Abends
HeisenbergHeid, Senuit18, MrMagan05, der RaupenHugo und Dotpolarized
Mehr sehe ich leider nicht
Doch, Kommandostich und Schafos, mehr sehe ich nicht
Willkommen im Streben
Dasepholy, wusstest du eigentlich von dem FaceReveal von EnoTricks wie er aussieht?
Ich glaube schon
Wann hat er denn FaceRevealed?
Als erstes Mal habe ich ihn auf der Gamescom getroffen
Und ich glaube da hat er doch nicht FaceRevealed
Glaube ich, keine Ahnung, aber da wusste ja auch von mir keiner wie ich aussehe
Also ich weiß es nicht mehr, kann sein
Ja, dann war das vor 4 Jahren auf der Gamescom
Ich weiß es nicht
Ehrlich gesagt, jetzt wieder die zeitlichen Abläufe waren so, genau
20cm deutscher Stahl
Hast du einen LPG-Cert und verwendet ihr Docker?
Ich habe keinen LPG-Cert, ich habe mir schon, ich überlege mal seit Ewigkeiten einen LPG zu machen
Also wirklich, also erstens sehe ich nicht so was es mir direkt bringen würde, wenn ich das mache
Und auf der anderen Seite bin ich sehr faul, was sowas anbelangt
Das wird mir was bringen, wenn ich mir mal einen neuen Job suchen muss, will, was auch immer
Aber so jetzt, weiß nicht
Ich spiele schon jahrelang mit dem Gedanken, ob ich es nicht mal machen soll
Also, es gibt ja mehrere Stufen von
Und ja, wir verwenden Docker
Beziehungsweise wir verwenden Container
Allerdings gibt es ja noch mehr Frontends
Also noch andere Frontends als Docker
Habe ich eigentlich aktualisiert hier? 3, 2, jawoll
Da waren ein paar huge Shatters dabei heute
Ich hoffe die werden auch mal geklippt und nicht nur immer meine Fails
Habe ich eigentlich schon erzählt, dass ich in irgendeinem Overwatch Wind und Fail Video gelandet bin?
Hat mir heute einer auf Twitter gepostet
Guck mal ob ich es finde
Was ist denn?
Hm
Hat mir heute jemand gepostet auf Twitter
Das kann doch nicht so lange her sein
Ah hier
Overwatch Daily Moments Episode 258
Funny and Random Moments
7 Minuten, wir können es ja mal zusammen angucken, es ist total unspektakulär
Display Capture
Ah Moment, ich habe hier schon Display Capture
Hier Display Capture
Da und da bin ich dabei mit irgendeinem Clip bei
Also da irgendwo
Ja das ist mal, boi die Quali ist aber mal unter unter aller Sauer
Ich weiß nicht wie sie den Clip gefunden haben
Das ist wo ich mit dem Reinhardt hemmere und danach wird das Game abgebrochen
Next Level Hammer, Kick to Reno geht ab
REKT 5K REKT
Fand ich ganz lustig
Wie funktioniert das mit dem Nightbot? Was meinste?
Du musst ein Kommando schreiben und dann antwortet dir der Nightbot was
Also du kannst zum Beispiel Ausrufezeichen Grill machen
Und dann kriegst du den Amazon Ref Link zu Krills
Ich mein wer jetzt was anderes vermutet hat, sollte mal seine Twitch D Gewohnheiten überprüfen
Bereust du eigentlich früher welche gepusht zu haben ohne Namen zu nennen?
Ja
Ein
So wird er da
Bb
Ganz cute
Jo
Go Go
3-2 also das Flawless Winning Stream hat sich erledigt heute
Aber nachdem wir so viel die letzten Tage gewonnen haben es ärgert mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
Und ich würde vorschlagen wir hätten mal den übelsten Losing Streak da machen wir einfach 3-4 Losses in Folge
Sonst ist der Tilt einfach so übertrieben dass wir dann nächsten paar Tage keinen Bock mehr haben zu spielen
Das muss ja nicht sein
Ich glaube eines der größten Fehler die man machen kann ist quasi trotz mega Tilt immer wieder direkt nach dem Game zu sagen weiter queueen
Siehst du ja auch in Streams total oft
3-4 Stunden von Match zu Match
Ja gut was soll man machen
Du kannst einfach Pause machen
Ja aber danach fühlt es ja trotzdem nicht besser
Ist ja nicht das Problem mit anderen Spielern
Ne das nicht aber du hast dich wahrscheinlich schon wieder ein bisschen abgeregt dass es dich da nicht mal ganz so sehr nervt
Mercy Main btw ist bei uns
Na der wird aber mal hoffentlich Mercy spielen da kann ich als Lucio spielen
Wille
Mercy Main btw hat übrigens 64 Stunden Tracer und 33 Genji
Und Mercy gar nicht
Hat Zia
Zia das bestimmt Grill
EL Grill 27 Stunden Mercy sonst nichts
Jawoll
Da muss ich jetzt aber bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal gucken
3700 einfach mal so
Ist jetzt fies ja so exposed
Letzte Season gibt es nicht zu gucken
Ok letzte Season 3100
Ok letzte Season 3100 Diamond
Mercy das liegt nicht an Mercy
Das ist einfach die kontinuierliche Weiterentwicklung und Verbesserung in-game gewesen
Von 3000 auf 3700
Kommt jetzt hier
Flank Attack
Kommst du?
Oben
Das wissen die Leute da unten nicht
Ich hab gerade ein bisschen überhaupt nicht gecheckt auf welcher Zeit aus sind
Schön den Schild ballern so wie es das gehört
Leute ich hab direkt alle rausgezogen
Wir werden krass gelasert
Overextende des Todes
Ich cappe mal mit der Mercy noch sofern es geht
Nein geht nicht
Das war Massive Overextended
Ok Respawn
Das war wirklich krass Overextended von den anderen beiden
Der Doomfist wird gefistet
Oben rechts ist das Area
Gehen wir
Mitte Mitte
Nein Doomfist nicht
Doomfist hatte ich gedacht Mitte ist
Was?
Ist ja gar keiner mehr da
Die sind alle verreckt
Super
Ok ich hab Bronze Damage
Das geht nicht so gut gerade würde ich sagen
Oh jetzt kommt er mit dem Hanzo
Ja auf
Move dich alter
Komm her
Ja da ist es Weihnachten
Was ist denn das hier?
Das läuft ja richtig gut
LastHero fragt was ist denn gebated?
An emote
Das läuft ja richtig gut
Helpläute
Wir haben Punkt
Oh mein Gott
Charge mal ein bisschen old
Ich gehe mit den Münzen drauf
Da muss jetzt mal was umkippen
Oh das ist jetzt
Ja
Wo seid ihr denn hin
Das ist ja massiv unkoordiniert das Zeug wieder hier
Ja das ist die absolute Uneinigkeit
Ja genau, sollen wir pushen, sollen wir zurückgehen, dann pusht man und denkt auf gehts und dann gehen wieder alle zurück
So jetzt kann ich dann was machen
So wirklich groß eigentlich Probleme hervorgestochen, weil die Gegnern ist jetzt eigentlich keiner wo man was gegen machen müsste
Das das Cap sagt, ich finde den Heal von Lucio zu weak
Nee der Heal von Lucio ist richtig so
Vor allem wenn Ana mal wieder irgendwann Meta werden sollte
Dann Metallgranate, das ist schon extrem nice
Wenn Lucio jetzt noch mehr heilen würde, dann wäre er wieder must pick
Wir wollen wahrscheinlich links contesten, weil wir nur Risse haben aber nix zum spammen
Was ist das wieder für Musik
Tracer hinter uns
What the fuck
Was ist das
Keine
Was ist das schon wieder ey
Kein Schimmer
Gibt es den Ausrufzeichen, das ist eher 3700
Das ist aber ein Failgame gerade
Egal
Auf Leute go
Ich bin jetzt als erster drinnen und keiner mehr mit mir
Oh meine Fresse ey
Da geht gar nichts
Das ist auch null, da fällt überhaupt nichts um
Ich habe gleich Ulti
Moment mir geht die Seite raus, auch gut
Ja
Also das ist gleich schon mal
Das ist halt late master ab hier geht es nur so weiter
Kann aber eigentlich gar nicht sein
Ist halt wirklich so, weil die Leute sind zwischen pushen und nicht pushen
What the fuck, was war das
Ich nehme ein
Oh Hanzo willst du jetzt die Tracer solo oder was
Die Tracer kommt, oh man ich muss sofort zu euch, der Hanzo stirbt wahrscheinlich gleich gegen die Tracer
Hier läuft
Ja Hanzos gegen Tracer gestorben, prediction Leute mega prediction oder zurück
Echt
Pass auf da kommen welche durch
Ich habe hier auch wieder hin
Es lebt das Todes ey
Pushen die Leute mal, pushen die
Ich habe das, oh man da kommt keiner mit, kannste vergessen
Jorissa steht einfach nur da shit
Nice weiter weiter weiter weiter
Nice, pass
Hinter dir hinter dir
Das war fail
Get ticked on
Das hat nicht so funktioniert
Zieh mal raus, oh ne bist du das, ne die andere
Das war halt von Anfang an fast schon zum verlieren verurteilt
Waren wir noch eins spielen
Ja eins waren wir noch
Eins waren wir noch, komm 4-3 jetzt easy win
Ich kann ja mit so Team setups wie Orisa fast gar nichts anfangen
Das war ja auch noch kacke gespielt, du kannst mit Orisa hier wunderbar Leute mit dieser Minicraft auch runterziehen und sowas
Aber unsere Orisa hat ja nur links oben gestanden und hat sich null bewegt, obwohl rechts dann gepusht wurde und sowas und an Stellen wo du nicht mal richtig reinschießen kannst
CP outdated genau wie Conquested, wat
Ja aber das mit dieser Orisa Kugel hängt halt auch immer nur davon ab ob der Gegner wirklich so blöd ist da ein Abgrund zu stehen
Ja, zumal die auch immer die andere Seite gepusht sind, da ist kein Abgrund
Das wäre doch eh nicht funktioniert
Aber das sind so Games die machen mir am wenigsten Spaß, die tilten mich auch richtig krass, du weißt nicht was dein Team macht
Der eine der macht halt seine Solo-Flank-Action und dann geht der nächste rein und disengagert sofort wieder und du bist halt gebaitet und am Arsch
Ich finde das ist auch eines der größten Probleme die das Flank-System hat, nicht dass es im Endeffekt nicht stimmen würde
Das wird sich wahrscheinlich durch diese SR-Geschichte jetzt durch dieses Performance Zeug erledigen
Aber so wie es jetzt ist, dass du halt total viele Games hast wo du die Gegner fistest und im nächsten Game dich die Gegner fisten und du halt wenig wirklich gute, voller Qualität gute Matches hast
Das ist das was ich als eines der größten Probleme hier vom Matchmaking sehe
Sam Fischer fragt ob ich Dino Flask kenne, nein das sagt mir gar nichts, was ist das?
Ne jetzt hab ich noch nicht geguckt
Sam Fischer schick mir mal das lustigste Video was du da findest von dem, das können wir uns dann gleich nochmal angucken zusammen
Oh eine Dosy P-Map, das hat uns jetzt gefehlt
Wir können wenigstens attacken
Da habt ihr schon alle drauf gewartet chat oder? Falls der Patrick noch da ist, der finde das bestimmt geil mit der Mercy Place
Geiles Setup, richtig cool
Was haben wir denn? Widow, Junkrat, Hanzo, Sop
Was denn das?
Das ist das letzte Abfall Setup, das kann keiner, keiner kann einen Mid-Pack nehmen, keiner einen, das geht nicht
Ich hab angefangen zu lesen, Mercy, Widow, Reinhardt, Junkrat, hab ich mir gedacht, oh cool, ey, nice
Und dann hab ich gesagt, Hanzo, Sopra, nein
Willst du zu mir?
Hanzo lässt einfach sterben, damit er es lernt
Ich versteck mich einfach hier
Ich weiß den jetzt runter
Ich freue mich schon auf das Netzneutralitätsvideo auf deinem YouTube-Channel, ja das dauert aber noch ein bisschen
Ich kann nicht die ganze Zeit bei dir stehen
Wir haben keinen Healer sonst
Ja die haben Sombra, haben sie sich verentschieden, Stärmeproblem
Hanzo, haben die überhaupt ne Widow oder Gegner? Nee
Ich muss da jetzt heilen
Huge Stress
Sag, wenn du irgendwas brauchst da oben, oh Gott, was, warum kämpfen wir überhaupt hier drinnen?
Mit Unterzahl
Ja, da kann ich jetzt nichts machen
Von hinten spampt ein Junkrat mich an
Huge Shatter vom Reinhardt, Massive Shatter
Also wenn das so durchgeht, dann ist das, ja
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich auch weil die Gegner noch mehr abkacken
Kannst du auf mir bleiben? Mit Damage
Kann aber sein, dass ich gleich runter muss
Junkrat kriegt rechts schon richtig auf den Sack
Ich geh runter
Ja, ich muss ab und zu aber andere heilen
Jetzt kann ich wieder zu dir
Ich hab gleich Ulti, nee, ich geh nochmal wieder runter
Komm mal, die verrecken jetzt nach vorne
Die sind nicht verreckt, ernsthaft?
Wieder, wieder, wieder, ich komm zu dir
Sag mal wo die ist
Unten links sehste doch
Ich seh sie nicht
Jetzt seh ich sie unten links
Wow, ich hab keinen
Okay, ich geh mal runter
Bleib mal unten, solange die wieder hier unterwegs ist
Bleib hier in der Ecke, da kannste nichts net viel machen
Oder am besten oben in der Ecke
Wenn das ein Schild oben hat
Komm hoch, Hanzo, Hanzo
Lass das Schild oben, Reinhard, lass das Schild oben
Hier wurde was wieder am Start
Tracer kommt links, irgendwo
Reinhard, man, lass das Schild vorne
Willste das die mich ficken oder was?
Hinter dir, Tracer
Hanzo
Die wollen einfach nicht das
Gut, wo, wo, ah da, auf dem Standard Spot
Was war das für ne Runde?
Was ist dein Lieblings das?
DPS?
DPS? Ah, du meinst DPS Hell?
Ich spiele eigentlich relativ wenig DPS Hell
Und wenn ich DPS Hell spiele eigentlich hauptsächlich Soldier
Oder wenn es sein muss sowas wie Reaper
Was ich gar nicht drauf habe einfach
Erstens aus dem Grund, weil ich es bisher kaum geübt habe
Sind die ganzen Flanker
Und irgendwie macht es mir auch nicht so großartig Spaß
Also was mir am meisten Spaß macht
Ist eigentlich die rechte Hälfte an Helden
Also den Tank-Teil und den Support-Teil
Außer Mercy jetzt mal ausgenommen
Wo mir jetzt allerdings oftmals nichts anderes übrig bleibt
Außer Mercy zu spielen
Wir könnten jetzt eigentlich mit Lucio richtig fett drauf pushen
Die Info, too many snipers, too many defense heroes
No tank heroes
Das ist geil, oder?
No tank, too many snipers, fail
Ich glaube wir verkackten jetzt genauso wie die Gegner
Was haben die Gegner da eigentlich getrieben?
Das war auch wieder so ein komplett unentschlossenes Team
Was einfach nichts macht
Afghanen dagegen rumstehen
Aber wenn ich mich, Harpoon, wenn ich mich für einen DPS-Hero entscheiden müsste
So nachdem auch den spiele ich am liebsten
Dann würde ich sagen Soldier
Aber sonst von allen Helden insgesamt eindeutig Ana
Macht mir mit Abschon am meisten Bock
Leider gerade nicht so richtig dicke mit dabei
Jetzt kommen huge Grapple-Hook-Jump-Shots, 360-Kills, oder?
360 kann ich mal probieren, wenn ich oben bin
Du musst aber auf, hörst du Shadowplay an?
Ja
Gut, gut, dann go
Go for 360
Also noch sehe ich nichts
Die verrecken da drüben schon auf dem Weg zum Tor, Alter
Ich mal für Sexy
Ich reds mal einen
Nee, die haben Schild
Das wäre ein Headshot gewesen
Moment, was geht jetzt ab?
Ich sag dir, wir verlieren das auch noch mit diesem Gamma-Setup
Kann gut sein, wenn ich mir das angucke
Nice Pick
Das ist definitiv das letzte Game, jetzt fängt Wochenende an
Ich geh mal zu unserer McCree rein, wir gehen jetzt
Oh, ich bin gehuckt
Fuck, Drecks
Okay, go, go, das müssen wir haben, das müssen wir haben jetzt
Die Symmetra hat noch keinen Porter
Ich weiß nicht, wo du bist genau, aber
Easy, easy clap
Nee, dann lass mal auf
Ja, 4-1
Das sind jetzt Games, die sind auf Brausel-Niveau
Das macht doch keinen Spaß mehr
Huge Symmetra-Plays
Sick, absolut sick die Plays
Oh Mann ey
So, mal kurz Punkte klotzen
Der Chat gibt dir Recht
Aber das merkste
Also oftmals sind die Games am Wochenende echt
Na ja
Es ist halt eine Tragödie, weil die Leute nicht die kennen
Die spielen kaum, beziehungsweise spielen fast gar nichts
Loggen nur am Wochenende ein und dann hast du halt solche Matches
Ich mein, du musst dir mal überlegen, das richtig lächerliche ist ja, war das Sache
Dass ich halt diesen 3 auf dem Main nicht mehr gespielt hab, ne
Aber wenn du queest, kommste in Highmaster-GM-Games
Was denkt sich dieses Matchmaking-System eigentlich dabei?
ETF
Das sah aus wie bei mir auf Platin
Ja, Harpun, genau das Gefühl hatte ich auch gerade
Du hättest dir mal, ich weiß nicht Harpun, warst du gestern mal am Stream dabei?
So geile Games gehabt
So geile Games gehabt, so richtig geile, krasse Plays auch gemacht
Alle samt
Und heute waren ja schon wieder echt so
Fail des Todes dabei
So, wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich, bei wieviel?
Das eine Game, oh, Fruit66, das war ja noch so einigermaßen, ne
Das war mit Abstand das beste Game, was wir heute hatten
So rein vom Spielablauf her
Aber alles andere war so, naja
Ja, das auf Fruit66 war ganz nice, zumindest der Anfang
Die Games, wo wir gestern hatten, die waren endgeil
Da hast du so richtig das Gefühl gehabt, dein Team ist fett am rein, drei Harden, jeder probiert was
Und hast du nicht gesehen, das ging voll gut
Ja, gestern war ein E, also gestern war wirklich der wünschtlichste Todesabstand und es war geil
Warst du schon mal auf GM, ja in Season 1?
Aber da war das noch nicht GM, ne, da gab es doch noch diese Season 1, gab es doch diese komischen Level noch
Mhm
Da warst du einfach nur eine Zahl
Ja
Ich glaub, GM warst du irgendwie ab 70 oder so
Ja, so in den Drehungen
Ganz am Anfang war es geil, da warst du irgendwie ab 63 top 500, weil es doch so gepackt war alles
Das war schon geil
Ja Leute, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen, wir machen den Schluss
4 zu 3, leider kein flawless winning stream
Season 1 gab es nur einen GM in EU
Es gab doch in Season 1 überhaupt keine GMs oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Stimmt, du hast recht, damals war GM noch höher als top 500, das war so ganz merkwürdig, stimmt du hast recht
Du hast recht, ja klar
Das war am Anfang total wir, du warst top 500 und quasi nur ein ganz kleiner Teil von top 500 war wirklich GM
Das war noch komplett umgedreht, stimmt, ja
Stimmt, stimmt
Ich hab dir einen Link gepaustet im Chat
Ich seh keinen Link
Ah hier
Weißt du was jetzt noch fehlt? Ein Game zum Ausklinken
Was meinst du?
Was hast du gesagt, ich hab es nicht verstanden
Ich hab es nicht verstanden
Was meinst du? Was hast du gesagt, ich hab es nicht verstanden
Ich meine, ein Game zum Ausklinken fehlt jetzt noch
Game zum Ausklinken, Yeti Hunter
Hab ich noch nicht gespielt
Das steht auch nicht mal im... Wo ist das überhaupt? Wo kann man das überhaupt spielen?
Arcade, ne?
Ne, das ist zu doof, hab ich keinen Bock drauf jetzt
Ach einen Overwatch meinste
ich werde jetzt ein bisschen level in bdo aber auf stream muss ihr irgendwann mal 60 werden
da muss ich dich alleine lassen ja passt da guck ich mir jetzt noch das video an was
jemand geschickt hat im chat gucken wir uns mal an mal gucken ob das eines dieser funny videos ist
die gar nicht funny sind oder ob sie wirklich funny sind ich mute mich mal kurz im discord
werbung woodface werbung gehe weg ok gucken wir uns jetzt mal zusammen an
ich mach discord mal aus gerade wobei ich bin gemütet das passt jetzt gucken wir uns
zusammen also video von dino flask jeff kaplan upcoming patch may christmas skin ok mal gucken
was da abgeht sind wohl merkwürdig zusammengeschnitten geschnitten interviews
schauen wir mal bild blies man sieht doch ein bild oder ja klar man sieht bild untertitel
aber noch an komm wir machen die untertitel auf deutsch falls es die gibt so guckt man mal
gebatet
Wir haben viel von deiner Feedback gehört, was die Symmetrie-Change betrifft.
Und wir haben gehört, dass die neue Symmetrie überwacht werden könnte, weil die Leute im Vorfeld von ihr melken.
Aber ich persönlich kann nur Symmetrie spielen.
Und ich will wirklich versuchen, den Grandmaster zu bekommen, bevor das Ende der nächsten Saison kommt.
Also haben wir in dem 2017en Patch die Distanz des Beams ausgestattet.
Sie ist jetzt ein langweiliger Beam-Sniper. Sie wird jetzt mit kleinen McCree-Striken verwendet.
Es ist Mittwoch, jede 3 Sekunden.
Also war ich ganz schockiert.
Wow, das klingt super wundervoll und zerbrochen und unabhängig.
Aber ich kann nur diesen besonderen Geschmack der Symmetrie spielen.
Also sollte das viel Spaß für mich sein.
Also eine große Veränderung, die wir auf der Scoreboard haben, ist, dass ihr jetzt seht, wer am schlimmsten auf eurem Team spielt.
Also könnt ihr sehr politisch die Person sagen, hey Dude, vielleicht solltest du dich auf meinen Lijiang-Tower zerstören.
Und dann f***** dich selbst töten. Das sollte viel besser werden.
Ein weiteres Feature, das wir planen zu geben.
Es ist etwas, das immer wieder gebeten wurde.
Also, wenn ihr Ponzo in einem kompetitiven Spiel spielt, wird euer Spieler-Level
Also, schaut euch das an, früh im neuen Jahr. Es sollte viel Spaß sein.
Wir wissen, dass es viele andere Probleme mit dem Spiel gibt.
Zum Beispiel Roadhog, Kinghook und andere Spieler von einem Seite des Universums zum anderen.
Die Zeit ist sehr lang und es gibt eine riesige Anzahl von Angriffen aus dem kompetitiven Spiel.
Aber ich möchte mich wieder einmal für alle politischen Mitglieder der Overwatch-Kommunikation verabschieden,
die sich über Maze-Saisone-Legendary-Skin verabschieden.
Du hast gesagt, wie wichtig es für dich war.
Also bis Ende 2017 werden wir komplett auf DLC-Kosmetik-Rewards arbeiten.
Also, wir denken, dass ihr das genießen könnt.
Ich bin gerade aus dem Zeitpunkt.
Also, wir machen wieder Overwatch-Rewards und wir hoffen, dass wir bald noch eine dieser Developer-Updates mit euch machen.
Danke an alle.
So.
Gut.
Machen wir mal Schluss.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Und ihr wisst ja, das Übliche, wenn es euch gefallen hat.
Like, Subscribe, Comment, Donate, Follow, Twitter, Twitch, Facebook, Instagram, Tumblr, Snapchat, Patreon, MySpace, StudiVZ und alles, was es so gibt.
Und machts gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Jetzt den Friseur.